de friend's just 70 years ago
a statement of les bent ten minutes
was going to change the destiny of the
qontinent frans the voice of robert schumann
reached out to germany and beyond europe
schumann propolis de gesture of
solidarity
solidarité that is become a de facto
solidarity  and where to wwf comb since
am on holistic range of energy to
education of pharming toe culture
of my journal of first to external
affairs
equally sweet medical mars progres that
objectif
or solidarity is silent though it and
motives goal shofar
montfollet ben ever dit solidarité was
which  to the test at the beginning of the
current pandemic
this crysis hash ona's met being you
were looking is not the answer and then
historic sharing and helping each
other day factor solidarity
er scene hospitals and check a
treatise i van french and aversion
passions of italy that we floatel
clinics in germany  en luxembourg
delivering medical equipment to spain
this solidarity must continue
week and only the fetus wise influence
take responsibility for each other to
work together to find often see how join
forces to get our economy often
evade for tactile save the rudder the
european green deal this  solidarity
chestnut self evident is needed in it
requires effort and compromise on every
one sport
but while this effort to our citizens
and to future generations
try schumann was definitely light
eye wish you a happy you all day long
live your on and drag europe
who had via